C'était une chance historique
pour les Russes de réformer leur
pays. Au départ, c'est un
moment... ça dernière phrase, il
nous a prévenu que le monde
n'était jamais si près de la
guerre mondiale, si près de
l'apocalypse nucléaire.
Aujourd'hui, la responsabilité
de ça, j'étais toujours critiqut
que l'Occident n'a pas saisi
cette chance qu'autrefois dans
le poste communiste, tout ça a
contribué à la crise que nous
vivons qui est une crise
absolument terrible. Les Russes
détestent aujourd'hui
Gorbatchev, mais ça ne veut rien
dire. Il restera un personna
de l'espoir. Simplement,
le système qu'on a construit, le
système des accords,
déséquilibre des intérêts,
existe plus. Je pense que
l'équilibre des inc'est
un monde qui doit revenir à sa.
Je parle aux Russes et aux
occidentx,
mais pas la guerre. C'est le
message de Gorbatchev.
- Je reviens sur une des choses
que vous avez dites. Il a tendu
la main gné le prix
Nobel de la paix. Il s'est senti
voyant que l'ouest,ignotait tre
territoires de l'ancienne URSS.
Il s'est dit que ça ne devait
pas être comme ça.
- Mais l'Occident, il ne faut
pas sous-estimer le rôle de laba
télévision que vous présentez si
bien. Regarder la télévision et
comparer les gens. Même Chirac
en France, les Américains, tout
ça, et comparer cela avec les
gens d'aujourd'hui. Le message
de Gorbatchev et le message de
recherche de la paix, ce n'est
pas du tout le message de la
guerre. La médiocrité de la
période actuelle saute aux yeux.
Avec son départ, regardant dans
le miroir et recherchons la
paix.
C'est sa volonté qui a changé
les choses.
Ma femme dit que Gorbatchev a
tendu la main à l'Occident avec
le coeur. L'Occident a pris le
coeur et a refusé la main. Donc
il paix très chère avec ce qui
se passe. Je voulais prévenir
vos spectateurs. Vous ne le
faites pas, heureusement, mais
beaucoup de gens en Occident
mélangent la propagande et la
politique réelle.
Gorbatchev ne faisait jamais.
C'est pour ça qu'il restera...
j'ai eu la chance de connaître
Jean-Paul II. C'est un message
pour la paix.
- Monsieur Poutine se sert de ce
déclin de l'empire comme étant
le moteur idéologique dans sa
guerre en Ukraine.
mesure Gorbatchev ne lui a pas
donné l'occasion d'aller à fond
dans cette théorie
revanche?
- Non, la théorie de la
revanche... il ne faut pas
construire le narratif.
Ce n'est pas la théorie de la
revanche. Poutine reflète une
grande blessure de l'opinion
publique qui a pensé qu'il était
prêt à 80 % à aller vers
l'Occident. Il s'est senti trahi
dans ses dispositions. Et
Poutine construit quelque chose.
Vous comprenez, Gorbatchev n'est
pas le seul fautif. On ditqu'iï.
C'était quelqu'un qui étaitre e.
il a eu une sorte de volonté de
regarder vers l'avenir. On n'a
pas cette chance pour le moment.
Je pense que c'est le dernierset
au bord de l'apocalypse.
Éloignons de la propagande. Jett
un grand journaliste, vous ne le
faites jamais, mais le
journalisme occidental tombe
aujourd'hui dans la propagande
éhontée.
- Quelques seconde
vous laisser aller.
Il a aussi fait libérer des
Ce
ça n'a jamais existé comme ça je
tiens à vous dire qu'aujourd'hue
très grave.
Je vis en Occident et je ressens
quelque chose non seulement par
Poutine, la liberté de la
presse,
mais je tiens à vous dire que
nous avons un grave problème de
n du politiquemen correcte.
Les vrais enjeux c'est la paix,
la recherche de la paix.
- Voilà, vous dîtes les leçons
de Gorbatchev sont aussi
importantes pour Poutine que
pour l'Occident que pour l'Ouest
également.
Embrasserai parler, parce que on
va refaire le point sur cettgue.
- Quand vous voulez.
Je tiens à vous dire aussi comme
je suis ukrainien : l'intérêt de
guerre, personne recherche la
paix aujourd'hui, en et en
gardant tous les côtés, et avec
mon expérience parce que j'ai
participé comme fossoyeur avec
les communistes à ce processus,
je tiens à vous dire qu'il faut
être très pointu dans l'an